okay so more from hollywood because all
it does
is choke out propaganda so you guys
remember john stewart jon stewart was
the host of the daily show for about 20
years uh 18 19 20 years something like
that little known fact some of you may
know this i actually interned at the
daily show in 1999
uh when jon stewart had just taken over
you may remember that craig kilbourne
who was a former espn anchor a guy i
really loved in college he was the first
host of the uh the daily show and then
john took over it was a very weird time
to be there because there was a lot of
turnover they were firing a lot of
people their senses of humor were
different so there was a lot of churn
there but it was it was a formative
experience i was doing stand up at night
i was interning there during the day i
was working at electronics boutique
which you now know as gamestop uh in my
free time so i could have a little
little money eat some food i was eating
a lot of tuna back then i'll probably
die of a mercury overdose because that's
all i could afford
in any event over the 20 years that jon
stewart hosted the the daily show you
know there was a idea out there that
this is where young people get their
news and it's that's what everyone kept
saying this is where young people get
their news and it was a culturally
important
show right and then you know and he was
sort of a
basically a good liberal like sort of it
was before woke-ism really uh he
completely went in on trump derangement
syndrome and then he dipped out uh as
trump had his four years so he kind of
went away for a while now he's back
apparently with a show on apple tv and
he's gone full woke he's gone full woke
these lefties and this is like the bill
maher thing i always talk about they
just don't know when to stop
thus
the problem with white people
hold on
i'm just gonna
i'm just
i'm just gonna stop for a second and
and pose so you can get your memes out
okay there we go
get a good picture for your clickbaits
for however sincerely we want to reckon
and listen the truth is america has
always prioritized white comfort over
black survival
it's such boring [ __ ] and trust me
it went on and on and on and he had a
ridiculous panel
where he was basically applauding as a
white woman was calling a white woman
who seemingly didn't know she was white
calling all white men evil this stuff is
so yes america has always been based on
white comfort all the men who died in
coal mines and who were laying track and
died and got burned in horrible
accidents in oil rigs and all of those
things it was all done in the name of
white power so that white comfort
ultimately could rule the day this is
the best maybe not for much longer and
you freaks are doing a pretty good job
of destroying it this is the best
country in the history of the world jon
stewart give up your show man what are
you doing you're a white dude you're a
white dude okay uh maybe you should give
up your show and give it to a black guy
is there not some black guy that could
do comparably what you do you're
pandering woke [ __ ] what are you
doing why are you taking the 10 million
bucks i'm sure it's got to be at least a
10 million a year deal from apple tv
right that's a lot of money why don't
you give it to a black guy but you're
not going to do that colbert you're not
going to do that jimmy kimmel you're not
going to do that you're just going to
tell white people how horrible they are
and it's like man
i've just had it with these freak
freaking people but the funny thing
about jon stewart is the same thing as
bill maher which is he sometimes kind of
gets it and then you see all these
people that are like oh my god he kind
of gets it he's a liberal who's not a
complete [ __ ] it's a miracle my god we
should somebody should say something
it's so wonderful you may remember a
couple months back i believe this was
june when jon stewart was on uh the
colbert show and even though for a year
and a half a whole bunch of us were
saying uh do you think that maybe covid
was a lab leak well jon stewart said it
on colbert and then suddenly everyone
was allowed to talk about it i think we
owe a great
debt of gratitude
to science science
has in many ways helped ease
uh the suffering of this pandemic
which was
more than likely caused by science
so there was a chance that this was
created in a lab there's an
investigation a chance well i don't i i
i i oh my god evidence i'd love to hear
that there's a novel respiratory
coronavirus overtaking wuhan china what
do we do oh you know who we could ask
the
wuhan novel respiratory coronavirus lab
the disease is the same name as the lab
that's just that's just a little too
weird don't you think and then they ask
those scientists they're like how did
this so wait a minute you work at the
wuhan respiratory coronavirus lab how
did this happen and they're like
a pangolin kissed a turtle
there's been an outbreak of chocolaty
goodness
near hershey pennsylvania what do you
think happened like oh i don't know
maybe a
steam shovel mated with a cocoa bean or
it's the
chocolate factory
maybe that's it that could be
all right i don't know is he funny
anymore like i don't know it's not for
me to say like it's just it is what it
is but the point is that after that
suddenly mainstream media said we were
allowed to talk about the the lab leak
before that people were getting banned
from twitter kicked off facebook shadow
band the rest of it from all of the
social media sites for even questioning
that maybe there was a lab leak
maybe there was a lab leak that led to
all of this so so john gets some stuff
right but he's unfortunately this is
what happens and there's a reason
there's an entropy to it why do so many
of the supposed good liberals or these
people who are not complete idiots i i
don't think john in his heart is a
complete idiot i really don't i think
he's probably mostly a decent guy but
once you go into that thing on the left
once you go into collectivism once you
go into wokism there's nothing you can
do to defend yourself against it because
now you have to bow because at the end
john you are now uh i don't know 60 year
old white guy
you are a six year white guy so you know
you have to bow to the activist base so
give up your show i really mean that
give up your show
give up your show or at least john you i
have no doubt i mean you must be worth
50 million bucks at least give up 20
million bucks to help young black tv
hosts get shows
if you really believe any of this but
none of them believe any of it